je m'appelle anthony zamani farhi j'ai
27 ans je travaille au technocentre
renault et ma fonction et 6 d'être ce
qu'on appelle pilote composants
enjoliveurs de roues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon activité au quotidien consiste à
être garant des règles techniques le
métier je suis responsable technique des
enjoliveurs de roues mon but c'est que
le client soit au maximum satisfait mon
objectif est de permettre au design de
concevoir l'enjoliveur le plus beau
possible et qui répondent à nos règles
techniques côté nous enjoignent rit on
parque moment où renault va se demander
sur quelle sera l'ange oliver de demain
du véhicule de demain et c'est là où moi
je vais devoir souvent intervenir pour
donner mes préconisations techniques
personnellement j'interviens beaucoup en
france avec l'équipe en local mais on
est en support de tous les équipes au
monde qu'on peut avoir que ce soit au
brésil en roumanie en inde en corée
[Applaudissements]
je suis content de venir travailler ici
je suis renault parce que je pense il ya
mama pied c'est ma fonction quand je
fais un enjoliveur j'ai un lien
particulier glauque les ans parce que si
je fais un oliver qui au final est beau
tout simplement je sais que le client
peut être content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]